vous dites la ferme il a est pathétique
car on refait les mêmes erreurs qu avant
charlie tout le monde devrait la
défendre elle ne peut même plus aller à
l'école et ce type de menaces ont déjà
été suivie mais d'abord je suis venu
pour essayer de débattre d'un sujet qui
est grave et de ma façon dépassionnée
d'accord je suis bien mohamed sifaoui je
ne savais pas que j'allais rencontrer
tariq ramadan à ma droite en moins par
les moines avant que tu veux parler du
monde dans l aventure cela dit j'espère
on aura viola dans quinze jours tout
mais là tout de suite je vais commencer
mais je me bats les c pas bon non mais
là trois ans ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire quoi islamistes violeur alesi au
bout de basket ont dans la tête des gens
c'est ce que tariq ramadan représente
c'est pas un islamologue c'est pas
quelqu'un qui n'est pas dans la tête des
gens quand vous dites ça vous essayez de
sous-entendre que je serais un islamiste
que je serai quoi que ce soit je sais
pas qu'est ce que vous apportez à la
société vous je me le demande je ne sais
pas qu'est ce que vous a apporté
[Applaudissements]
ben oui ce que j'apporte c'est de vous
mettre dans cet état au moi ça me fait
plaisir
alors on va être dur vous aide à vous
êtes mis là d'une part pourquoi pourquoi
que c'est pas un match de foot entre
l'om et le psg c'est pas je suis psg où
je suis au m
le jeu suit à une histoire il ya
beaucoup d'ignorance
il faut le rappeler il y a une histoire
autour d'eux je suis d'abord c'était
kennedy face au mur de berlin et qui
dirige been berliner ça veut dire je
suis solidaire avec les berlinois de
l'est qui sont en train de souffrir
jean marie colombani quand il était
directeur du monde au lendemain du 11
septembre fait un excellent édito ai dit
je suis américain et la phrase célèbre
je suis charlie vient de cet esprit ça
veut dire je suis solidaire avec la
victime
je suis en empathie avec ceux qui
souffrent je suis solidaire avec ceux
qui sont persécutés
voilà ce que ça veut dire si cette jeune
fille et christine kelly a eu a bien
fait de le rappeler qui n'a que 16 ans
avais je dirais dit ce qu'elle a dit
sans qu'il y ait de réaction d'une
menace je n'aurais jamais dit je suis
mineur il ya pas de raison mais du
moment qu'elle est menacée
oui je suis mis là pourquoi parce que je
m'inscris dans une vieille tradition
moi qui étais élevé spirituellement et
idéologiquement dans une école de pensée
de gauche je suis mis là comme je suis
spinoza quand il se fait excommunié par
les rabbins à amsterdam
je suis mis là comme je suis voltaire
quand il est face à l'église cathédrale
terre du pauvre je suis bi là comme je
suis diderot comme dans des verrines
saut je suis mis là comme je suis
charlie hebdo
oui je suis mis là comme je suis les
femmes iraniennes qui se font persécutés
quand elle porte pas le voile je suis
mis là comme je suis le vic la victime
de tous les saoudiens repos vie
assassine au nom de l'islam depuis
quelques années depuis plusieurs années
pour qu'elle ait quelqu'un ils sont
réduits en mine de rien oui mais
attendez
même si ensuite 16 ans alors oui mais
qu'ils soient dus en mai sur twitter
aujourd'hui en soit dur mais qu'il soit
dur je les fais encore une fois je je
les reverrai terre une extension dès le
moment où elle est menacée parce que
rien absolument rien ne peut justifier
une fille de 16 ans puissent être
déscolarisés cyber harceler oui je
dirais c'est toujours là toujours dont
juste jeu là tous disent les jeunes est
interrompue personne
non mais des personnes lundi parce que
tout le monde l'a dit au contraire
personne n'a dit sans rajouter le mais
non ce mais voilà que j'ai déjà entendu
mais pas demain
après les attentats de charlie hebdo me
gêne terriblement parce que il met une
condition suspensive d'une certaine
façon où il met même un âne ou latif où
se tient je soutiens mais ça a été pas
loin
je soutiens charme mais quand même il a
fait des dessins qui ont déplu et ça je
suis désolé quand on soutient un
véritablement on ne peut pas rajouter de
mai en soutien sans condition après une
dernière année c'est aussi la saison
derrière elle et le dernier l'italie me
semble-t-il né en 2003 oui cette
génération de 2003 soyons sérieux
qu'est ce qu'ils ont vu de l'islam
qu'est ce qu'ils savent de l'islam ils
ont vu c'est une génération qui a vu en
france mohamed merah qui a vu les
attentats commis au nom de l'islam par
les frères kwasi qui a vu les attentats
commis au nom de l'islam au bataclan qui
a vu des jeunes de leur âge ils ont vu
des gens de leur âge mourir à nice parce
que écrasé par un camion
ils ont vu et des religieux des compris
des musulmans mourir et musulmans y
compris y compris des musulmans mourir
laissez moi juste finir près au nom de
l'islam donc que l'islam au nom de
l'islam à redon rendement de loursac il
au moment de les voir nando lice la vie
bravo du nom de l'islam
libre à vous des chronos mulliez rouen
ce site jihadiste libre à vous moi je
n'ai pas cet automne n'a jamais dit guy
naury d'arrivée avouant médicaux à
minuit les salafistes djihadistes je
vous dis bravo moi je n'ai pas cette
autorité morale
oui mon rôle et je mange très bien joué
et bien vous faire ma conception de
l'islam manger que bienvenus
s'ils sont aujourd'hui il était en jeu
et musulmans pour moi je vais juste très
clair une chose c'est que dans l'esprit
d'une gamine de 16 ans qui v qui vit son
époque
il faut savoir aussi faire sa petite
introspection
lorsqu'on parle au nom de l'islam
l'islam est très mal représenter l'islam
et aux yeux donc ce sont quand on perd
c'est une religion mc de meurtre et de
haine elle le dit et oui l'islam des
salariés était une religion de merde
c'est pas islam des frères musulmans est
une religion doit ce n'est pas ce
qu'elle dit c'est cette vague gagner oui
mais je dis oui je dis c'est un vide et
ça c'est un peu différent jeudi ce
qu'elle voit jeudi ce qu'elle voit elle
voit ne s'est pas n'a passé sur cc je
dirais sa cape à 5 ans une capacité de
l'intellectuel n est pas suffisamment
charpenté à 16 ans elle n'a pas fait
suivant des rallyes la glace qu'elle n'a
pas dit mais vous le dis devant elle a
dit on ne sait jamais vraiment parce
qu'à l'attaqué en plus interdit
d'ailleurs la justice il a fini vous
déjà baissé juste en place et une parce
que quand on est sûr de ses arguments on
écoute les années laissez moi juste en
place deux minutes que je voulais un
message qu'on croyait qu'on n'entend
rien tant sur tous les plateaux tv redon
j'ai fait mais je peux faire je fais là
le byblos y voit si vous prenez ça veut
dire mais je vais après je voulais juste
rester derrière cette génération qu'on
le veuille ou non est une génération qui
est impacté par cette époque post 11
septembre ou en avait on a vu
malheureusement je le dis
malheureusement islam s'est exprimé que
pas d'un banal par les générations c'est
de poursuivre et pitoyable ensuite il y
à une réalité qui n'est pas perçue par
tout le monde il ya aujourd'hui trois
liaisons rapides un peu je veux
d'ailleurs conseil il ya un livre
formidable qui a été publiée par le
cercle le corps en vue par les
historiens qui fait un travail des
passionnés et qui permet de remettre le
coran dans son historicité
il y a un travail qui est fait par deux
je dirais universitaire bernard augier
et au méchant qui met ça n'a rien donné
en évidence à la grande librairie
l'autre réalité il a elle ne s'appuie
pas sur la lecture des livres que vous
venez de citer
j'aurais été dans un département non
merci
10h07 cette émission où on vous invite
en fait les gens parlent à votre non non
c'est pas faire une place mais je mets
poids maintenant vous mais c'est pas un
bonheur des balances ton pote c'est un
débat tout à l'heure j'ai les haïr la
drogue
peut-être vous voulez éliminer le patch
pour faire du mot faire du buzz dites
moi même année les jeux serrés loaec
dans votre doctrine
si on dit je suis mis là c'est la fin du
débat mais je regrette en tout cas c'est
pas la politique de l'émission puis
c'est pas non plus la culture française
on peut être je suis mis là et quand
même essayé d'expliquer de remettre en
question certaines choses en perspective
d'autres vous vous dites moi je suis là
c'est fini a pas deux mais y'a pas si il
peut y avoir pas des pas des mêmes mois
mon soutien et inconditionnelle mais ce
qu'elle dit est ce que vous vous dites
en disant il ya des livres
universitaires milla n'est pas ce
niveau-là et massa est pas des lapins à
la centale dit le coran c'est de la m
l'islam c'est de la merde excusez moi
great je lui dis simplement et je
rejoins bernard qu'elle ferait mieux de
grandir un peu de s'instruire un petit
avant de sortir des trucs werner des
conneries